um Isa Marco so you guys y'all have a
dance scene in the movie how was that it
was so good I saw it actually yeah was
it
the first day the damn sequence happened
my first day it was like I landed and
first they sent me like oh this is they
told me it was going to be a dance
sequence in there I was like oh cool
that's that has nothing to do with me
and then they sent me like the footage
to rehearse it and I was like you know I
was I had something that I was doing in
DC and I had to learn it in like 24
hours and the cast had been already
working on it and so I was like this is
literally my worst nightmare I'm not a
dancer so I like tried to learn the
routine I was with my friends they were
like girl get it like one two one two
get it one two three four and then when
I landed they were like oh the dance is
completely different
so then I landed my first day of meeting
the Cavs was doing this dance number and
it was what a way to break the ice yeah
way to break the ice in my face yeah my
pride
with us because that was honestly the
funnest part of prepping this movie is
doing we do dance rehearsals like for
probably two weeks this is definitely
why it was so stressful for you because
you didn't get the two weeks like that
we would all go and I'd been doing it
for like a week on my own and I was like
oh this is so fun because it's like the
kind of dancing you do like with a
hairbrush in front of your mirror when
you're a kid so it's like silly fun
dancing but then like the other Barbies
all started arriving for the dance
rehearsal and then I was like my ego
went through the roof because they were
like like everyone's screaming and
clapping and then we do it all together
and then we'd get like everyone before
shooting we'd get our whole crew and
everything to do like a little dance
warm-up together and it was so fun like
just the vibe the rest of the day would
be amazing I don't know if you know but
Drew I mean you guys were hers too I
know that y'all y'all dance I know that
you can dance it out you want to show
some moves where you want to show us
some moves guys
why
why are you backing up
are you doing Kid and Play
[Music]
thank you
I love my favorite part was your restart
you were like no we didn't get it from
the top
you can tell the year you were born by
that dance alone it's the same year as
me
I don't
impressive we have an impressive crew 11
Emmys they got nominate 11 Emmys
impressive audience everyone's dressed
up amazingly
[Music]
[Applause]